welcome back to Las Vegas now Kirby of
Schofield Realty is back and today it is
all about winning the bidding war it's
going to get intense but first the first
meeting we're going to talk about is
working for you yes um we need more
agents because we got many clients and
many homes to sell well
not as many homes to sell now uh
oh yeah you want to elaborate on that
so our inventory has shrunk once again
it's uh less than two months inventory
like it was last year oh wow and the
bidding wars have commenced okay so
explain what the concept is a bidding
war means you're a buyer you want to get
that house there's going to be multiple
people trying to get it so make sure
that you are informed on what you're
offering on and you're qualified and
ready because it's not just you offering
on the home more than the last six
months you've had kind of that freedom
right right and having Someone Like You
by their side guiding into the process
because what is the strategy so our
strategy is we use data not what your
mom and dad are telling you
uh not um I'm a Zola Flex partner in
town very proud with Zilla but the
zestimate don't go off the zestimate
it's an estimate so that's another thing
um but choosing realtor call our team
will actually go through the data of
what's sold and what you're actually
going to get on an appraisal okay so you
actually know uh it's what you can
actually afford all right now you have a
few specific tips so we're going to
start here with should you offer on
multiple homes so how we write our
contract you are able to write offers on
multiple homes okay okay and the reason
we say that too is you're going you may
get beat out on one of them uh at least
you have a try at the others and even if
you get beat out on one another tip is
if your game being out asks the other
side to leave it as a backup offer okay
once that escrow falls through well what
about paying appraisals up front that's
something so paying appraisal upfront is
a strategy we do too where uh sometimes
to be if that seller's wanting more and
we may start seeing that again where
they're pricing it way over what we
think the comps would be is pay for the
appraisal up front and see where it
comes in at before you due diligence all
your other contingency start the seller
will like that because it sees the value
and then you can see if you're even
getting it before the other
contingencies which could possibly lose
your earnest money okay and then you got
they gotta call you to get the tips on
inspections protecting the amount you
put in from if there's a lot to learn
yeah yeah thank you Kirby thank you
Scofield Realty thank you for sponsoring
this segment all you got to do is visit
scofieldrealty.com or call
702-941-7202 for more information that's
a nice tattoo
[Music]